Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. I was going to talk to you guys today
about the.
So let me back up.
A week ago, I imagined that today I would
be talking to you about the U.S. anti-vaccine
mandate trucker convoy heading to Washington,
D.C., set to arrive today.
Their plan was to get to D.C. on the day of
Joe Biden's State of the Union address a week
ago.
I thought I'd be talking to you about it.
I'm not because nobody's paying attention
to it, and it's not even clear that it seems
to have sort of disintegrated.
And one aspect of this is brought up in this
voicemail, and our voicemail number again
is two one nine two David P. Which is what
mandates are they protesting anyway?
Take a listen.
Speaker 6: Hi, David.
I have a question for you, and I have always
and they've pretty much been overturned by
the courts, especially if you don't buy that
federal warrant in the airports and everything
else is pretty much overturned by the courts.
Am I wrong?
So why are the convoys still forming and still
trying to make their way across America and
other places doing it too?
And.
They have a much further cause if they just
pick up their guns and go to Ukraine, Kyle
Rittenhouse, to go with them.
He wanted to protect a storefront but to protect
the country with their patriotism that Trump
calls them all patriots a true patriot.
But to do something patriotic, even if it
is for another country, at least it shows
it gets the ball.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So listen, a couple of thoughts on the U.S.
charter convoy.
First of all, Matt and I tweeted about this
yesterday, and many of you wrote back absolutely
loving it and saying you had thought the same
thing.
Imagine that you spend a month or six weeks
or however long it was organizing this convoy
of truckers that wants to protest vaccine
mandates and government tyranny and authoritarianism,
and you're going to drive across the entire
country.
I don't remember where they started, whether
it was California, Arizona, somewhere in the
southwest or maybe Texas.
Who the hell even knows they're going to drive
to Washington, D.C.
And then quite literally, as they're about
to leave to start their convoy, Russia invades
Ukraine and gets 24-7 coverage, and no one
pays attention to your stupid convoy.
So like, that's number one.
And that's funny, and I genuinely take pleasure
in it.
That's hilarious.
Nobody's paying attention to these people
because Russia has invaded Ukraine.
But then there are other layers of absurdity
that are Kafkaesque in this entire thing.
The second one is the whole premise of the
trucker convoy is that these are victims of
tyranny and authoritarianism, right?
We are being victimized by the tyrannical
government, mostly state governments that
say, Hey, you got to be vaccinated against
COVID.
And quite literally, Russia invades Ukraine
and people start dying, and the president
of Ukraine is out there fighting.
And you, as a trucker are trying to say, I'm
a victim of tyranny.
When you see what's going on in Ukraine beyond
parody, OK, so that's like the second layer
that's that's funny or, you know, curious.
And then of course, the third one is what
the caller is saying.
What mandates are you protesting?
So the general Biden vaccine mandate, which,
by the way, wasn't a mandate because encouraging
it include or allowed for a test out option,
you can opt out and test instead.
That was blocked by a court.
You then have states and municipalities that
have various vaccine requirements.
You've got to be vaccinated to work in health
care setting, or you've got to show a vaccine
card to go to a restaurant or whatever.
They're mostly dropping it because why?
It was an imaginary slippery slope all along
as COVID is waning for now, fortunately.
And who knows what the future holds?
Variants Spike's resurgence.
Cases are down 95 percent.
And exactly as the sane people expected as
the threat from COVID goes down, various requirements
are being eliminated.
There is barely any mask requirements left.
Yes, you've got to wear masks on airplanes.
There's some, some cities and places that
but the mask requirements are going away.
The vaccine requirements are going.
It's all going away.
So what are you even protesting at this point?
It's really an example.
This entire U.S., the Canadian convoy was
this, but the U.S. trucker convoy is even
more so this.
What are you protesting at this point?
What on earth are you protesting?
And they're just desperate for attention,
which they're not getting?
Thankfully, not thankfully, that Russia invaded
Ukraine, but thankfully as a result of there
being real news in the world.
Nobody's paying attention to that stupid convoy,
and I'm absolutely loving every minute of
it.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
First of all, what would it look like if Ukraine
joined the European Union?
How would it work?
What would it look like and what would be
Putin's reaction?
We're going to talk about Ukraine and the
EU on today's bonus show.
Secondly, hackers have been very involved
in the Russian invasion of Ukraine, taking
down a number of prominent Russian websites
and doing a whole bunch of other stuff.
And one of the recent things that happened
is that 120000 Russian soldiers have been
doxed by hackers, meaning that their identities
and their personal information has been released.
And we're going to talk about, obviously that
is is not in the realm of what we typically
consider cyber warfare.
But where does that type of thing fit in in
international military conflicts?
There are differing opinions it might sound
like.
No, no, no, no.
Here's the here's the one view on doxing soldiers
and its validity.
But they're actually some dissenting views
on that.
We're going to talk about that and the number
three.
Yesterday, I told you that FIFA has determined
Russia Russian players can play in the World
Cup, but no Russian national anthem and they
can't be identified as Russia.
That's been canceled.
Russia has now been totally thrown out of
the World Cup.
FIFA has decided they're just it's just too
hard.
No, and we're going to talk about that and
other kind of sports related sanctions that
have come in the past and that may come in
the future.
All of those stories and more are on two days
bonus show.
How do you get access to the bonus show?
Simple sign up for a membership at Join Pacman
dot com.
You can use the coupon code.
Please don't war.
I know it sounds ungrammatical, but that's
what it is.
The coupon code is please don't war.
You'll get a discount off of a membership.
You'll get access to the bonus show, the commercial
free audio feed, the commercial free video
feed, and much, much more.
We will see you then and tonight live on YouTube,
Twitch and Facebook for Joe Biden's State
of the Union address.
I hope you'll join me.
Unidentified: I will see you that.